so what's up with battlestar galactica
because i heard about it for a while and
then i know that there's the movie and i
know sam is working on a series and like
how what exactly what can you tell fans
i can tell fans that um i'm done with
the second draft of the script
and
um we are in the process of um going out
to directors
and the hope is to um attach a director
and start prepping the movie this year
it's a
magilla humongous film
and the prep will be a very long prep
period so i would imagine even if we
attached a director today it would take
six nine months to prep this movie
properly so at the earliest we'd be
shooting at the end of this year we'd
probably be shooting at the beginning of
next year
um
time will tell who the director is and
then
and then you or someone else will tell
who the director is um
uh in terms of the the the
the situation with sam and the show
um
i can't say too much about it other than
there is synergy
between the two and the two enterprises
and
um constant communication between us
we've become close um and been having a
really good time together um and there
will be
um uh for lack of a better phrase and
it's an overused phrase a shared
universe
i understand i have to i mean listen i
love battlestar galactica and i'm
incredibly excited that you guys are
developing something so for fans of the
series that was on a decade ago or
whatever does it connect to that or is
this like a completely new thing
gosh um
you're asking me a hard question that
i'm not sure i'm allowed to answer um
there is there are connections
but it isn't it is certainly not simply
a continuation
or a remake of
um ron moore's masterpiece